We're wrapping up 2019, 2019 has been an year
in many ways and one of those ways has been
a a one of, one of the ways that we've seen
the insanity of 2019 has been through the
total fake non controversies that have been
promoted by the American right-wing office
in service to distracting from something actually
horrible that Donald Trump has done. And media
matters put together a very good list of what
they are calling non traverses non controversies
in 2019 that have appeared on Fox news. And
I want to remind you about a couple of them.
And before we do it, we do have real scandals
happening and real stories.
We have protests for democracy and rights
in many places around the world. We've seen
an explosion of extremist white nationalism.
The president has been impeached. We've had
more than a mass shooting a day for the entire
year. The United States president is a laughing
stock around the world on and on and on, but
on Fox news, check out some of the things
that were scandals, the Gillette razor ad,
which was directed at men in the me too era
showing bullying and sexism and saying, Hey
men, you should behave. Fox news went nuts
saying it attacks men. We saw the James Bond
controversy actors, Daniel Craig and Pierce
Brosnan who have played James Bond historically
saying they would be supportive of a female
double Oh seven like LeShawna Lynch who will
be cast as double O seven in an upcoming movie
and there was outrage. How the political correctness
of a fake a James Bond.
How could James Bond be a woman? Chick-fil-A,
of course, Chick-fil-A is saying in 2019 they
will no longer donate to anti LGBTQ organizations.
Fox news said this was Chick-Filet crumbling
and bowing to left wing attacks. We saw a
lot of mass shootings in 2019 two big ones
were in Texas and Ohio and after those universal
pictures said, we're not going to publish
our movie. The hunt, which depicts deplorables
being hunted by elite liberals as they couched
it because it was in horrible taste given
the mass shooting problem that we have, and
Fox said, this is evidence of the hypocritical
left. They want division, they want to go
after Trump voters, but they also say they
are against gun violence. What a scandal.
In 2019 Fox news talked about a war on Thanksgiving.
Check this out. Here's a summary from media
matters.
We've heard about the war on Christmas, but
now called students are declaring a war on
Thanksgiving. Forget the war on Christmas.
The left is outgoing after Thanksgiving. This
was as the war on Thanksgiving and they want
to fight a war on Thanksgiving. They lost
the war on Christmas. They want to fight again.
PC police, while they have a new target, Thanksgiving
cancel culture has turned on the holiday.
Cancel Thanksgiving dinner. Very sad to announce
we have to cancel Thanksgiving all across
America. A growing number of students and
professors claim we need to throw away or
turkeys, no Turkey, no traveling cranberry
sauce and mashed potatoes are bad for the
planet. Trump also
sang at a rally that the left wants to not
call it Thanksgiving. All of this apparently
was, uh, catalyzed by an article in Huffington
post called the environmental impact of your
Thanksgiving dinner. Wow. Clearly a call to
cancel Thanksgiving. What a scandal. And then
of course there's always the war on Christmas.
The war on Christmas is always a scandal year
in and year out on Fox news, among other enclaves
of the right. If they put as much energy into
fixing real problems rather than creating
new ones. Think about how much better off
we would be. Imagine if Fox news instead of
propagandizing or about a Gillette ad said,
Hey, we have hunger in this country and it's
optional. We could decide at any time we are
not going to have hunger anymore. We're not
going to have people go hungry. We could fix
that now. Instead, they've got to do the Gillette
ad.
Imagine if they said medical bankruptcy must
end. It's time for us to join the fight for
a solution instead of being part of the problem.
Now instead it's liberals want to cancel Thanksgiving.
Uh, and of course the real big Metta scandal
at Fox news is Fox news continuing to carry
water for an unhinged liar of a president
while perpetuating baseless conspiracies and
pretending conspiracy theory is better said
and pretending to be a news station rather
than opinion. That is not going to change
in 2020. The only question is, are they fully
with Trump or not? And we will see as we get
into 2020,